[Music]
hi I just suppose editing this and I
thought I'm probably going to have to
insert myself here to try and explain
myself more because I was extremely kind
of in the zone this day and that's what
I wanted to show me being in the zone
working but when I get in the zone
sometimes I find it really hard to
externalize what's going on internally
I was just rambling not making much
sense so every now and then I might pop
in and right now I am post-rock night
had suffered but we'll get through this
anyway yeah maybe maybe see you later hi
so thoughts for today's video it's been
a while I realize that a lot of the time
why I make things and why I want to
share it I'm trying to make people
realize that if you have a dream if you
have an idea if you want to be creative
no matter like how old you are or how
where do you think it's gonna be you
should just do it and get it get it done
you should just do it obviously it's not
that easy but my point is just to do
things and have fun with them and stop
worrying so much but as I have grown and
made cooler progressively cooler and
cooler things not to my own horn or
anything interactive videos and then
video games and then you know well
produce music stuffs I'm like thinking
that I'm on a ladder that I always have
to top and that's really difficult for
YouTube I'm in a loop of perfectionist
impatience because I'm trying to get out
a video once a week but in my head that
video always has to be a new music video
or like any of this only that because
those are the things that I enjoy and I
guess I just haven't found my little
niche of what could be in between so
anyway today I really want to show you
that I am NOT some crazy wizard which I
was you can do these things too I keep
getting messages and stuff and honestly
I just feel like my imposter syndrome is
just up here guys my impostor syndrome
is like sorry be on my tiny little head
I'm just gonna show you how I work today
today my goal is I have been looking
into using unreal to export music videos
[Music]
and this is all mainly just because I
have a song that I want to release and I
don't want to release it without a cool
video I want
to release this by tomorrow I'm just
filming this because hopefully this will
keep me accountable and maybe you can
see that the decisions that I have to
make to actually get things on time or
sometimes the decision that I have to
make to think no this project deserves
more time and deserves to be better but
I do you really just want to get this
done because I want to keep working on
my game perfection okay I'm going I'm
wearing really make a copy because
[Music]
[Music]
so to start the day off I'm gonna do
probably the most pretentious thing you
guys would take the piss up before
that's something yo ger just stuck my
head out and figure out what the plan is
for today what is the minimal that I can
do so I can maximize my time I think
it's done Jaeger is over what magical
things nothing but so I was thinking
about what I've learnt through the week
using unreal is that spider on my window
it's okay it's on my window but it's
outside my window so I know I can render
out 360 video I just I don't know how
simple it'll be because I've done it
before with unity and unity z' is yeah
great I love unity I miss I miss unity
but I'm even unreal I'm working in a
real I'm trying to learn new engine okay
the only thing with 360 is things
probably won't be in perfect time and I
was thinking I've got this green screen
and I was thinking of projecting videos
into the scene because right now there's
nothing that great about it it's less
you just the assets that come with the
store and stuff but I just pop them
around the place so I could take videos
of myself and then put it there on
screen and also I've used the spatial
like visi visualizer is that that's
called no audio visualizer something
like that plug-in to make these like
little rocks and stuff like dance to to
the beat of the music
it's they're lame but and I then I was
like oh my god I haven't made a 360
video Dages no video but what is that
not in time and no one even notices the
work that I put in to make the rocks
dance to do you think so I though I just
make it no more video output it o make a
360 either way I might try and do both I
might just try and make the sequencer
make the video and then make 360 out of
that video and then I can figure out
which one came out better so right now
what I need to do is just sort out the
Empire
and then I will start editing in the
editor after I have a shower and stuff
because they probably should take their
videos on green-screen if I wanted to do
green screen videos
[Music]
still haven't made the cave yet because
I was busy me cue the lights look great
I know didn't you make them we're gonna
make them too great cuz now I'm building
and it's taking about half an hour to
build them right this is oh I can get
everything done in the day forget that
technology takes time and you know also
it's not like I have a beasty earth
computer my spore technology I put it
through so much
[Music]
got a little bit attracted with a cute
little dog oh that my housemates
girlfriend Doreen I'm still a bit all
quickly I'm still very new to this house
and they don't really know that I do
these kinds of things but anyway it is
now a half past three so I've got my
scene set up I still need to do some of
the camera angles right now I am
building the writing and then I'm just
gonna no screw it I'm just gonna set up
the sequencer later so I know where I
want my projected video to be but I
still think that I want to so I have
like a default one there now but I still
think I want to film a new one using
green screen so it will blend with the
background a bit more so I should
probably do that and yeah maybe become a
bit more camera-ready
[Music]
you
[Music]
[ __ ] your value someone please show me
how to put this back in the bag one
thing that is a positive and a negative
thing about me once it get an idea in my
mind I cannot forget about it and I need
to get it done
I want this green screen to work inside
of unveil I know I could just put it
into After Effects and render it out as
a green screen video and then put it
into unreal but I wanted to work the raw
material and I thought it'll be easy if
it's not so I'm just gonna watch this
tutorial I still can't figure it out
then I'll put it into After Effects but
damn I'm hungry cuz it's like five six
o'clock now like but I'm at she had the
green screen working and unreal and now
she shoots pretty clothes it's pretty
cool she doesn't just look like a slob a
video texture on the game she looks like
she's in the game
so yes I still haven't done the sequence
yet though we have a lot to do today
it's nearly the end of the day I don't
know the person with nothing better to
do I guess why am I telling you
absolutely everything that you don't
care about why am i repeating myself so
much what's happened to me I thought
I've got dust on my camera also just go
completely off topic and just take a
moment to recognize that Slipknot are
number one on the Irish albums chart and
they freaking be Ed Sheeran look at this
dude I'm happy so I might I might sing
my own version of something
see it's on the shell our way down below
hello so how did I do after my day of
working because what's the time seven
o'clock at night 11 o'clock at night
normally and I really wanted to I would
just stay up all night and just get this
done however I'm a working girl now
I'm a working lass I've got work in the
morning and I am working in the games in
the street you know still working on
cool stuff at work too so unfortunately
I have to stop and I think this is kind
of what why I did this video 8 let you
know why sometimes videos I'm coming as
regularly be so you know that I am NOT a
superhero don't get me wrong
I love the compliments that you guys
give me like I'm really grateful and
happy for them it's freaking awesome
that you love what I make in stuff it's
just me on my laptop trying things out
it's kind of like how I see kids you
know they just wake up and they just
start to draw write a story and it's not
like I've made the most photorealistic
staff or anything like that I'm just I'm
just doing what I want to do and
honestly I really think any of you guys
can do it too
I guess all that it takes is just time
and motivation and just excitement I
wouldn't do any of this I wouldn't have
stayed in all day today and not left the
house and just been staring at a screen
even though that proves that what I'm
gonna do tomorrow and I go to work I
would not have done that if if I wasn't
excited about the stupid stuff that I'm
making and it's not the best thing in
the world it's not gonna bring me money
it's it's just because I enjoy
so yeah and also because of that I'm not
going to work myself through the night
and not sleep and then not be okay for
my actual paying job because that's just
gonna burn me out at the end of the day
and it's irritating and frustrating
because I can't keep to a deadline that
I give myself however it's different
because you do have to prioritize at the
end of the day and if this was my job it
would be different it would be great it
would be great to keep this fun and to
keep me being able to do this I need to
be kind to myself and know my own limits
and the same goes for you guys stop
going on Instagram and looking at my
profile no just stop comparing yourself
to everything everyone online and maybe
just spend a day just making something
and even if you don't get it finished by
the end of the day it's okay I haven't
got this finished I'm still gonna get it
done to some extent it won't be perfect
it's not gonna be perfect but it's gonna
be fun I've already learnt so much today
I'd never use sequencer before and I
know I've just made a little demo scene
and it's it's going way too fast so I
just look at the frames per second but
yeah there's so much stuff but I've
still got the land and that you guys
have got phones well we've always got
more things to learn just keep enjoying
the process of learning instead of
focusing on the end goal and feeling
like a failure if you haven't reached
some some crazy-ass deadline just keep
going this is also advice that I'm
giving myself because I do beat myself
up when I haven't managed to get another
video out for you guys but I would hate
for you to think that I'm not thinking
of you I am okay I got cool stuff on the
way it just sometimes it just takes a
while because you get caught into
something and you really really really
want to make it so anyway thank you so
much for your support I hope this was
somewhat entertaining even though I did
not leave my house
but maybe you get to know a bit
about me and the way that I work and
realize that I'm no superhero and you
can probably do this to you you know you
can definitely do this do you can do
this to have a lovely Gerry thing I'm
gonna out Tibet see if you ever get old
okay y'all now close the laptop he asked
me close laptop Oh